je vous montrais plusieurs personnalités
vous allez devoir me de balancer un
défaut sur un défaut une tare des foules
intéressant attention vous ne pouvez pas
utiliser le même défaut d'accord
benjamin castaldi ivoiriens se sont
moins bien que son père moins bien que
son père
huawei a le niveau était fait déjà pas
très bons amis c'est méchant pourquoi en
quoi moi bien que son père moins drôle
ouais je trouve moins drôle moi -
vivants - marc et foch le trouve aussi
les gentils bientôt ce sera peut-être
gentille mais pour moi ce pagne que les
faits patrice et là ils vivent à michel
sardou arrêté parce que je fous rires
comme négatifs mais celle sardo un
mauvais souvenir
amel a fait les choses je connais très
bien j'ai écrit toutes ses premières
chansons mais c'est vrai bien sûr aller
parole et puis un jour on s'est retrouvé
dans un qui s'appelait l'ailé s'appuient
les uns piane d'europe du peyrouat
l'époque je n'ai pas connu vous êtes
projet 78 comme tiger dad
rené branché série plein d'artistes
étaient là y avait tout le service
français je n'avais pas vu depuis quatre
cinq ans c'est un mec que j'adorais et
je le vois au bout d'une grande salle
comme ça je me précipite sur lui pour
lui faire la bise est tellement content
de le retrouver
il met la main comme ça en fait j'essaie
de l'embrasser il dit qu gentil pas
devant tout le monde et est depuis ce et
s'il ya une cassure parce que je m'étais
dit mais on a partagé tellement de jean
marc morandini
oui alors là oui - bien que sont faits
ce manipulateur
voilà j'ai dans le père satan attend on
peut revenir vite
vas-y pourquoi alors non pourquoi
mais gégé j'expliquerai beaucoup un peu
plus tard est inquiète patriciens tu
fais ce que tu veux julien lepers vient
le père se [ __ ]
[Rires]
l'attenté est grande
et
[Applaudissements]
les chevilles on va se retrouver dans un
instant monsieur avec patrice laffont
avec toute l'équipe et vous aurez les
explications sur cette insulte
concernant aussi bien le père patrice
laffont julien lepers pourquoi [ __ ]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
regardez ce qui s'est passé au regard de
julien lepers eu beaucoup et tu t'en
fous enfin série ce que tu attends
attends pas merde cyril ouais bah non tu
as trop vite il faut revenir sur julien
lepers alain julien lepers
je m'en fous non alors bien qu les
seniors julien lepers et du de lepers
[ __ ]
[Rires]
voilà c'était l'explication à voir
[Applaudissements]